Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
Supernatural took a relaxing spa break from
the war for heaven and hell in what I like
to think of as a cross between an X-Files
episode and a Scooby Doo Mystery.
Extra special shoutout for LunchLady Dean,
second only to Dog Dean.
Quick heads up before we get started, because
olympics supernatural isn’t back until feb
25th in three weeks.
So if you’re looking to re-watch an episode.
I would recommend first born or anything with
abaddon and crowley in it.
Since this episode was tailor made for funny
bits let’s do our Top 5 funniest moments
and then I’ll do my review.
Number 5 - Sheriff Donna, Dean and The Donuts.
Dean eating like a pig is always hilarious.
But we have to give credit to Sheriff Donna
for being his wingman on this joke.
She’s just casually stuffing her face with
white powder on her lips when the camera cuts
to Dean licking his fingers and looking like
he just stuck his whole face in that box of
donuts.
The best part is that Donna and Dean don’t
acknowledge it at all and Sam just sighs.
uuggh.
Number 4 - We Have All Kinds of Certifications.
They gave away lunchlady dean in the teaser
last week, so this wasn’t a surprise, but
just the preposition of dean in a hairnet
is epic.
He gets all the best fake jobs.
Not to be outdone though, the idea of richard
simmons Sam was good.
Seriously though, can we talk about how Dean
is always the one to jump in head first to
crazy situations.
And Sam always follows along.
It’s like Sam is still a little kid following
big brother dean around.
Even though he’s way taller and kind of
hates him right now.
Number 3 - Downward Dog for 5 minutes.
I’ve actually done yoga and 5 minutes in
one pose is a lot, but it’s not that bad.
I loved the look on everyone’s faces.
And the idea that Sam knew yoga because he
“dated someone bendy too”.
Number 2 - The Fat Vampires.
Saying it that way makes it sound like a really
bad Twilight spinoff.
But as gross as it was, it was really watching
sam and dean react to it all.
I couldn’t stop mentally associating the
pudding with the jars of fat in the fridge.
If you’re able to get through a cupping
session after this you are a champ.
Number 1 - Something is in the pudding.
Dean getting roofied is a little dark just
because of what roofies are normally associated
with.
But just watching him lust after the pudding
was the funniest part of the episode.
You have lunchlady dean getting dumped on
by his supervisor, who then tells him he can’t
touch the pudding.
So naturally Dean immediately runs off with
some.
How great is it that he ran into the closet
to eat it.
I just want a clip reel of Sam catching Dean
eating in weird places.
Like catching a dog eating off the table.
That’s a bad dean, that’s a bad bad dean.
I just see the crestfallen look on his face
now.
I’m sorry, i was hungry.
Let me know what your favorite moment was,
are you team yoga or team lunchlady.
I have to say, I’m lunch lady all the way.
I even sang the adam sandler song a little
when he showed up with the hairnet on.
Overall I had to give the episode a B minus
just because it was a retread of old material
in a new setting.
Plus sometimes Dean and Sam’s attitude’s
on monsters and killing is inconsistent.
In fairness to dean hating monsters, he still
has that mark of cain.
So that might be making him aggro way more.
I did have fun with the fat vampire twist
and the whole concept of the weightloss spa.
The health nut slash eating disorder satire
was a nice moral throughline.
Moderation is key, in all things both monster
and winchester.
If only dean could just learn to chill on
all the instant gratification.
I think the big journey for Dean this season
in addition to killing abaddon is learning
to be a real human being.
He’s kind of been living this parody life
up to this point.
Which is probably why he didn’t know how
to live without Sam and why he can never settle
down.
This deep in the season I feel like they really
need to be focusing on those main plot lines.
Like Crowley, Abaddon,Castiel and Metatron.
Gadreel is kind of like a second tier character
at this point.
I’m 99 percent sure they’ll get a season
10, so the real question is if Dean is going
to learn anything as a character, or if he’ll
still be dealing with the same personal issues
next year.
Let me know what you think yes or no, is Dean
going to be the same old dean in season 10.
If you didn’t see, I just posted a big preview
of grant gustin’s flash tv show.
Click here to learn all about it and click
here for last week’s supernatural.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight,
high fives!